Diddy's newborn daughter makes her
Instagram debut it was something that
that the fans wanted on Tuesday the
rapper gave fans their first look at his
new baby girl love Sean Combs that's
little love sitting in her car seat with
a pink blankie and get ready for
cuteness overload because here's Diddy
snuggled up with his new bundle of joy
resting her head on her daddy's shoulder
wearing a pink outfit with a matching
bow did he caption the post quote baby
love it's just love Diddy also shared
this family pick on Christmas Day
rocking matching Jammy sets that's love
in his arms alongside Diddy's other
children 24 year old Christian
21-year-old Quincy 16 year old twins
Jessie and Delilah and 16 year old
Chance missing from the photo was
Diddy's 28 year old son Justin and in a
second sweet snap we see Diddy's mom and
his son's girlfriend the cat caption
Merry Christmas from my family to yours
love oh man it means everything to me
Diddy surprised fans earlier this month
when he announced the arrival of his
seventh child tweeting that he is so
blessed and adding God is the greatest
it was you know it was just beautiful
since the announcement ET has learned
that Dana Tran a 28 year old cyber
security specialist is loves Mom I'm
dealing with Daddy emotions it seems
safe to say Diddy who changed his name
to love combs in 2021 is one busy Daddy
just last week he celebrated Jesse and
Delilah's 16th birthday with an
over-the-top futuristic themed Bash
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and like any epic sweet 16 the birthday
girls were gifted cars to be specific
matching Range Rovers
and I've been able to see my kids and
and give them that comfort of them
seeing me and everything's all right
it's a beautiful thing
[Applause]
yeah Diddy's clearly a mogul but one
thing's for sure being a dad comes first
that was my daughter a chance
[Applause]
in February he took chance as his date
to the Oscars first of all the biggest
thing that's going on tonight is me
bringing my daughter to this because
she's an aspiring actress and we get to
have a date and I I'm just so excited
and I'm just so stunned I'm at a loss of
words so I'm blessed to be here you know
we get
um I'm presenting tonight and we're
gonna have a good time but I'm like I'm
dealing I'm dealing with Daddy
emotionally when she walked out yeah
right right what did you say what did
you say what the [ __ ] is going on
foreign